[Musique]
pour les plus nostalgiques l'exposition
prisonnière le design pour tous au musée
de la ville de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
risque de réveiller quelques souvenirs
les magasins prisonniers qui ont été
créés en 1930 par les magasins le
printemps pour vendre des produits à
prix plus compétitif et initialement ces
magasins vendait à la fois de
l'alimentation des vêtements et de
l'équipement pour la maison et c'est
dans un deuxième temps et même
relativement bien plus tard à partir des
années 60 que l'enseigne va se tourner
vers la vente la vente de mobilier
design cette table très tôt qui était
assez ingénieuse qui est qui a été le
l'un des best-sellers de la marque qui a
été vendu à plus de 25000 exemplaires
c'est une table assez caractéristique de
la marque caractéristique par sa grande
économie de moyen leur encore on de très
tôt en métal avec un simple plateau bois
alors qu'il peut faire soit table haute
quand elle est dans cette position mais
aussi table basse quand on met les
tréteaux à l'horizontale un focus sur
une enseigne emblématique qui a
popularisé le mobilier design de
consommation dans les années 60 jusque
là les objets de design étaient des
piètres relativement cher signé de grand
designers clinique veut vraiment de
démocratiser cette cette production 120
pièces sont présentées au public elles
proviennent de la collection du musée de
la ville de prêteurs privés et du Musée
des Arts Décoratifs de Paris partenaire
de cette exposition le musée de la ville
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines pour
vocation de s'intéresser
aux modes de vie moderne et contemporain
et notamment
aux années 60 70 qui correspondent à
l'émergence d'une société de
consommation à l'équipement des foyers à
l'émergence d'une société de loisirs
c'est un grand tournant culturel dans
dans notre la société l'exposition est
accessible jusqu'au 7 janvier une visite
guidée proposée tous les samedis